because the American people need the
truth about the threat Tick-Tock poses
to our national and personal security
Tick Tock collects nearly every data
point imaginable from people's location
to what they type and copy who they talk
to by Electric data and more
even if they've never been on Tick Tock
your trackers are embedded in sites
across the web
check talk surveills us all
and the Chinese Communist party is able
to use this as a tool to manipulate
America as a whole
we do not trust Tick Tock will ever
Embrace American values values for
Freedom human rights and innovation
Tick Tock has repeatedly chosen the path
for more control more surveillance and
more manipulation
your platform should be banned
I expect today you'll say anything to
avoid this outcome like you're 100
responsible for what Tick Tock does that
you suddenly endorse a National Data
privacy standard
that project Texas is more than a
marketing scheme
that Tick Tock doesn't harm our innocent
children
or that you're ties to the Chinese
Communist Party through bite dance is
just a myth
we aren't buying it in fact when you
celebrate the 150 million American users
on Tick Tock it emphasizes the urgency
for Congress to act
that is 150 million Americans that CCP
can collect sensitive information on and
control what we ultimately see hear and
believe
Tick Tock has repeatedly been caught in
the lie that it does not answer to the
CCP through bite dance
today the ccp's laws require Chinese
companies like bite dance to spy on
their behalf that means any Chinese
company must Grant the CCP access and
manipulation capabilities as a design
feature
right now bidance is under investigation
by the doj for surveilling American
journalists both digital activity and
physical movements through tick tock we
also know that many of your employees
still report directly to Beijing
internal recordings reveal there is a
back door for China to access user data
across the platform
your employees said quote everything is
seen in China
a gateway to spy is not the only way
Tick Tock and bite dance can do the
bidding of the CCP
Tick Tock has helped you race events and
people
China wants the world to forget
it's even censored an American Teenager
who exposed ccp's genocide and torture
of uighur Muslims
the facts show that bite dance is
beholden to the CCP
and by dance and Tick Tock are one in
the same
Tick Tock also targets our children
the 4u algorithm is a tool for Tick-Tock
to own their attention and prey on their
innocence
within minutes of creating an account
your algorithm can promote suicide
self-harm and eating disorders to
Children it encourages challenges for
them to put their lives in danger
and allows adults to pray on our
beautiful beloved daughters
it's also a portal for drug dealers to
sell illicit fentanyl that China has
banned yet is helping Mexican cartels
produce send across our border and
poison our children
in China the CCP proactively prohibits
this type of tick-tock content that
promotes death and despair to kids
from the data it collects to the content
it controls Tick Tock is a grave threat
of foreign influence in American Life
it's been said it's like allowing the
Soviet Union the power to produce
Saturday morning cartoons during the
Cold War
but much more powerful and much more
dangerous
Banning your platform will address the
immediate threats
make no mistake this committee is also
looking to the Future America needs to
be prepared to stop the next
technological tool or weapon China will
use for its own strategic gain we must
prevent any app website and platform
like Tick Tock from ever spying on
Americans again and we must provide the
strongest protections possible for our
children that is why this committee is
leading on a national privacy and data
security standard it restricts sensitive
American data from reaching our
adversaries to begin with
and what big Tech and data Brokers
collect process store and sell it makes
it illegal for any platform to track and
Target children under 17.
Mr Chu the committee has requested that
Tick Tock appear before us for a long
time
for those we serve
we're glad the day has finally come
today the world is watching
fight dance is watching
the Chinese Communist party is watching
but the answers you owe are to the
American people
a free people who cherish they're
god-given unalienable rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness for
all
they deserve the truth
complete honesty is the standard and the
law you are being held to before this
committee as we seek to get answers and
a full understanding of what happens at
Tick Tock under your watch thank you
chair now recognizes the ranking member
Mr pallone for five minutes
thank you madam chair and let me say
that I agree with much of what you just
said and I certainly appreciate your
enthusiasm and your commenting on being
a mother and concerned about children
and I'm glad that we are having this
hearing today
um big Tech has transformed the
information superhighway into a super
spreader of harmful content invasive
surveillance practices and addictive and
damaging design features data is Big
Tech's most valuable commodity and by
collecting far more user data than they
need big Tech platforms can use share
and sell information to generate
billions of dollars in Revenue today the
American people are powerless to stop
this invasion of their privacy and we
can't wait any longer to pass
comprehensive National privacy
legislation that puts people back in
control of their data we must hold big
Tech accountable for its actions and
transparency is critical to that
accountability in the past several
congresses this committee has heard from
senior Executives of other social media
platforms about troubling and repeated
instances where they put profits over
people now today we intend to bring more
transparency to tick tock which is
controlled by its Beijing
communist-based parent company bright
dance and while Tick-Tock videos provide
a new fun way for people to express
their creativity and enjoy the videos of
others the platform also threatens the
health privacy and security of the
American people and I'm not convinced
that the benefits outweigh the risk that
it poses to Americans in its present
form more than 130 million people in the
United States use tick tock every month
including two-thirds of American
teenagers tiktok collects and compiles
vast troves of valuable personal
information to create an addictive
algorithm that is able to predict with
uncanny accuracy which videos will keep
users scrolling even if the content is
harmful inaccurate or feeds destructive
Behavior or extreme misbeliefs now the
combination of tick tock's Beijing
Communists based China ownership and its
popularity exacerbates its danger to our
country and to our privacy the Chinese
communist government can compel
companies based in Beijing like Tick
Tock to share data with the communist
government through existing Beijing law
or coercion National Security Experts
are sounding the alarm warning that the
Chinese communist government could
require Tick Tock to compromise device
security maliciously access American
user data promote pro-communist
propaganda and undermine American
interests dense information campaigns
could be launched by the by the Chinese
communist government through Tick Tock
which has already become Rife with
misinformation and disinformation
illegal activities and hate speech a
recent report found that 20 percent of
tick-tock search results on prominent
news topics contain misinformation
social media's profitability depends on
growth and engagement more eyes on their
content for longer time leads to more
advertising dollars and revenue
generation addictive algorithms are
fine-tuned to optimize growth and
engagement without necessarily taking
into account potential harms to users
children and teens are particularly
vulnerable frequent online use of
interactive media on digital devices is
associated with increased levels of
depression among middle and high school
students research has found that tick
tock's addictive algorithms recommend
videos to teams that create and
exacerbate feelings of emotional
distress including videos promoting
suicide self-harm and eating disorders
public outrage and Hollow apologies
alone are not going to rain in big Tech
Congress has to enact laws protecting
the American public from such online
harms and we simply cannot wait any
longer to pass the comprehensive privacy
legislation that I authored with then
ranking member now chair Rogers last
Congress that over overwhelmingly
Advanced out of the committee it ensures
that companies wherever they live it
ensures I should say that consumers
wherever they live in this country will
have meaningful control over their
personal information our legislation
establishes Baseline data minimization
requirements ensuring that companies
only collect process and transfer data
necessary to provide a service and it
provides heightened privacy protections
for children and teenagers so I think
it's time to make this legislation the
law of the land and we also have to
examine the reforms needed to section
230 of the communications decency act
the liability shield for social media
platforms has for too long been abused
and led to a lack of accountability for
social media platforms so I hope we can
find a bipartisan path forward on that
issue too and I think you're having a
hearing next week on it so we can stop
the very real harms to our country and
democracy under the current law I'd look
forward to the discussion today as we
continue to bring accountability to Big
Tech and let me say to Mr Chu I know
this is about Tick Tock but I am
focusing all my attention not only on
Tick Tock but on these concerns why
concerns about social media and the
protection of privacy and with that I
yield back thank you again uh Madam
chair for having this very important
hearing
are witness to our witness today is Mr
Chu Chief is executive officer of tick
tock you're recognized for five minutes
thank you chair Rogers ranking member
pallone members of the committee thank
you for your time
I am show Chu and I'm from Singapore
that's why I was born that's what my
parents and after serving in Singapore's
military I moved to the UK to attend
college and then here to the US to
attend Business School
I actually met my wife here by the way
she was just born a few miles away from
here in Virginia
two years ago I became the CEO of tick
tock
today we have more than a billion
monthly active users around the world
including over 150 million in the United
States
our app is a place where people can be
creative and curious and we're close to
5 million American businesses mostly
small businesses go to find new
customers and to fuel their growth
now as Tick Tock has grown
we've tried to learn the lessons of
companies that have come before us
especially when it comes to the safety
of teenagers
while the vast majority of people on
Tick Tock are over 18.
one of and one of our fastest growing
demographics are people over 35. we
spend a lot of time adopting measures to
protect teenagers
many of those measures are first for the
social media industry we for we forbid
direct messaging for people under 16 and
we have a 16 minute watch Time by
default for those under 18.
we have a suite of family pairing tools
so that parents can participate in their
teens experience and make the choices
they are right for their family
we want Tick Tock to be a place where
teenagers can come to learn which is why
we recently launched a feed that
exclusively features educational videos
about stem
stem videos already have over
116 billion views on Tick Tock and I
think Tick Tock is inspiring a new
generation to discover a passion for
Math and Science
and I would also like to talk about
National Security concerns that you have
raised that we take very very seriously
let me start by addressing a few
misconceptions about bite dance of which
we are a subsidiary
by dance is not owned or controlled by
the Chinese government
it's a private company
sixty percent of the company is owned by
global institutional investors 20 is
owned by the founder and 20 owned by
employees around the world
by Dance's five board members three of
them are American
now Tick Tock itself is not available in
mainland China
we're headquartered in Los Angeles and
in Singapore and we have 7 000 employees
in the US today
still we have heard important concerns
about the potential for unwanted foreign
access to U.S data and potential
manipulation of The Tick Tock U.S
ecosystem
our approach has never been to dismiss
or trivialize any of these concerns we
have addressed them with real action
now that's what we've been doing for the
last two years building what amounts to
a firewall the seals of protected U.S
user data from unauthorized foreign
access
the bottom line is this
American data stored on American soil by
an American company overseen by American
personnel
we call this initiative project Texas
that's why Oracle is headquartered
today U.S tech data is stored by default
in Oracle service only vetted Personnel
operating in a new company called
Tick-Tock U.S data security can control
access to this data now additionally we
have plans for this company to report to
an independent American board with
strong security credentials
now there's still some work to do we
have legacy US data sitting in our
service in Virginia and in Singapore
we're deleting those and we expect that
to be complete this year
when that is done all protected us data
will be under the protection of U.S law
and under the control of the U.S led
security team
this eliminates the concern that some of
you have shared with me the tech talk
user data can be subject to Chinese law
this goes further by the way than what
any other company in our industry have
done
we will also provide unprecedented
transparency and security for the source
code for The Tick Tock app and
recommendation engine
third party validators like Oracle and
others will review and validate our
source code and algorithms this will
help ensure the Integrity of the code
that powers what Americans see on our
app
we will further provide access to
researchers which helps them study and
monitor our content ecosystem
now we believe we are the only the only
company that offers this level of
transparency
now trust is about actions we take we
have to earn a trust with decisions we
make for our company and our products
the potential security privacy content
manipulation concerns raised about tech
talk are really not unique to us the
same issues to apply to other companies
We Believe what's needed are clear
transparent rules that apply broadly to
All Tech companies ownership is not at
the core of addressing these concerns
now as I conclude
there are more than 150 million
Americans who love our platform and we
know we have a responsibility to protect
them
which is why I'm making the following
commitments to you and to all our users
number one we will keep safety
particularly for teenagers as a top
priority for us
number two we will firewall protected
U.S data from unwanted foreign access
number three take talk will remain a
place for free expression and will not
be manipulated by any government
and fourth we will be transparent and we
will give access to third-party
independent monitors that remain
accountable for our commitments
I'll be grateful for any feedback that
you have and I look forward to your
questions thank you very much
as you know the testimony that you're
about to give is subject to Title 18
section 2 1001 of the United States code
as you stating your testimony bite
dances tick tock's parent company is it
accurate to say that you are in regular
communication with the CEO of bite dance
Leon robo
chair Rogers yes I am in thank you
communication with him okay
Kelly Zhong is the CEO of bite dance
China overseeing doyen the Chinese
version of tick tock are you in regular
communication with Kelly
I'm not in regular communication with
her
the bite dance editor-in-chief is Zhong
poo poo ping correct
I believe so
and woo
shoe gang is Beijing bite dance
technology board member and also an
official of the cyberspace
Administration in China is this correct
uh I believe so I they are not in direct
thank you all of these individuals work
are affiliated with the Chinese
Communist Party are not the highest
levels of leadership at bite dance a
company where you previously served as
the Chief Financial Officer where you
regularly communicate with their CEO
Tick Tock has told us that you weren't
sharing data with the CCP but leaked
audio from within Tick Tock has proven
otherwise to talk told us that you
weren't tracking the geolocation of
American citizens you were Tick Tock
told us you weren't spying on
journalists you were in your testimony
you state that bite dance is not
beholden to the CCP again each of the
individuals I listed are affiliated with
the Chinese Communist party including
Zhong Fu ping who was reported to be the
the Communist Party Secretary of bite
dance and who was called for the Party
Committee to quote Take the Lead across
all party lines to ensure the algorithm
is enforced by quote correct political
Direction just this morning the Wall
Street Journal reported that the CCP is
opposed to a for sale Tick Tock by bite
dance quoting a CCP spokesman is saying
the Chinese government would make a
decision regarding any sale of tick tock
so the CCP believes they have the final
say over your company I have zero
confidence in your assertion that bike
dance and Tick Tock are not beholden to
the CCP
next question
heating content
is a way of promoting and moderating
content in your current or previous
positions within Chinese companies have
employees engaged in heating content for
users outside of China
very quickly yes or no our heating
process is approved by our local teams
in the various countries the answer is
yes thank you
have any moderation tools been used to
remove content on Tick Tock associated
with the uyghur genocide yes or no
we do not remove that kind of content
Tick Tock is a place for freedom of
expression and challenges like I said if
you use our app you can go on it and you
will see a lot of users around the world
expressing content on that topic and
many others thank you what about the
massacre in Tiananmen Square yes or no
I'm sorry I didn't hear the question uh
the massacre in Tiananmen Square that
kind of content is available on our
platform you can go and search it I will
remind you that making false or
misleading statements to Congress is a
federal crime I understand again you can
go on our platform you will find that
content okay thank you
reclaiming my time can you say with 100
certainty that bite dancer the CCP
cannot use your company or as divisions
to heed content to promote Pro CCP
messages for an act of aggression
against Taiwan
we do not promote or remove content at
the request of the Chinese government
the question is
the question is are you 100 certain that
they cannot use your company
to promote such messages it is our
commitment to this committee and all our
users that we will keep this free from
any manipulation by any government if
you can't say it 100 certain I take that
as a no
as I previously referenced Tick Tock
spite on American journalists can you
say with 100 certainty that neither bite
dance nor Tick Tock employees can Target
other Americans with similar
surveillance techniques sure Rogers I
first of all disagree with the
characterization that is spying it was
an internal investigation yes or no can
you do surveillance of other Americans
we will protect the U.S user data and
fire it all from all unwanted foreign
access it's a commitment that we've
given to the committee so so I guess my
question is are can I want you to I
wanted to hear you say with 100
certainty that neither bitness nor Tick
Tock employees can Target other
Americans with similar surveillance
techniques that you did with the
journalists
again I don't disagree with the
characterization characterization is
surveillance and we have given our
commitments chair Rogers the four
commitments I think it's our commitment
that we will not be influenced by any
government on these issues doj is
investigating this this surveillance
right now
to the American people watching today
hear this Tick Tock is a weapon by the
Chinese Communist party to spy on you
manipulate what you see and exploit for
future Generations a ban is only a
short-term way to address Tick-Tock and
a data privacy bill is the only way to
stop tick tock from ever happening again
in the United States I yield back
I now yield to the ranking member for
five minutes
thank you madam chair let me just start
out by saying Mr Chu that I don't find
uh what you suggested with project Texas
and this far we'll uh that's being
suggested
um to whoever uh will be will be
acceptable to to me in other words
um you know the I still believe that the
Beijing communist government will still
control and have the ability to
influence what you do and so this idea
this project Texas is simply not
acceptable according to a recent report
Tick Tock Is On Target to make between
15 and 18 billion dollars in Revenue
this year is that an accurate forecast
Congressman as a private company we are
not sharing our I have no numbers how
much money will Tick Tock make by
delivering personalized advertisements
just to your users in the United States
will you give me that information
again Congressman respectfully as a
private companies are not disclosing
that look um my cons the impression
you're giving and I I know you know I
can understand why you're trying to give
that impression is that
um you know that you're just performing
some kind of Public Service here right I
mean this is a benign company that's
just performing a public service I maybe
you're not maybe that's not what you're
saying but it I don't buy it right my
concern here is primarily about the
Privacy issue the fact that Tick Tock is
um making all kinds of money by collect
Gathering uh private information about
Americans that um they don't need for
their business purposes and then they
sell it and I mentioned this legislation
that the ranking that the chair and I
have uh that would minimize data
collection and make it much more
difficult for tick tock and other
companies to do that so what if you want
to make some commitments today why don't
I'll ask you to make some commitments
with regard to this legislation and you
know you're going to tell me Well the
bill isn't passed and so therefore I
don't have to do it but you know you say
you're benign you want to do good things
for the public so let me ask you uh why
not what about a commitment that says
that you won't sell the data that you
collect
would you commit to that not selling the
data you collect Congressman I believe
we don't sell data to any data broken
you don't sell to anyone we don't sell
data to data Brokers I didn't ask your
data brokerage you sell it to anyone in
other words under our bill you can only
use the data for your own purposes not
to sell it to anyone would you commit to
not selling your day to anyone
Congressman I actually am in support of
some rules I didn't ask you whether
Bruce I asked you whether the company
Tick Tock would commit to selling its
data to anyone and just using it for its
own purposes internally I can get back
to you on the details okay get back to
me all right another thing that's in our
bill says that we would prohibit
targeting marketing to uh to people
under the age of 17 would you be willing
to agree to prohibit targeted marketing
to people Americans under the age of 17.
Congressman we have actually stricter
rules for advertisers in terms of what
they can show to our do you prohibit
Target would you be willing to prohibit
targeted marketing to those under 17
that's what's in our bill I understand
that there's uh some talk and some
legislation around this around the
country again I'm not interest I wanted
you to make that commitment without the
legislation since you say you're a good
company you want to do good things why
not
it's something we can we can look into
and get back okay I appreciate that okay
we also have in our bill a requirement
of heightened protection for sensitive
data particularly location and Health
Data would you commit uh to not uh
Gathering or dealing with location or
health data unless you get affirmative
consent uh from the consumer in other
words under our bill those are
categorized as sensitive and unless the
person specifically says I want you to
collect that data you wouldn't be able
to location and Health Data would you
commit to that Congressman in principle
I support that which by the way we do
not collect precise GPS data at this
point and I do not believe we collect
any Health Data all right so would you
be willing to make that commitment that
from now on you won't collect location
Health Data without what you're saying
at all
this is data that's frequently collected
by many other companies you know I know
other companies do it I don't think they
should without affirmative consent you
said you want to be a good actor so why
not make that commitment to me today
we're committed to be very transparent
with our users about what we collect I
don't think what we collect I don't
believe what we collect this morning the
problem here is you're trying to get the
impression that you're going to move
away from Beijing and the Communist
Party you're trying to give the
impression that you're a good actor but
the commitments that we would seek uh to
achieve those goals are not being made
today they're just not being made you're
going to continue to gather data you're
going to continue to sell data you're
going to continue to do all these things
uh and continue to be under the Aegis of
of the Communist Party through the
through your uh you know organization
that owns you so in any case thank you
uh thank you madam chair
gentleman yields back here now
recognizes the gentleman from Texas
merges for
five can I take the chair
thank you Mr Chu for for joining us
today uh I think we've heard you say
multiple times that Tick Tock is not a
Chinese company that by dance is not a
Chinese company
but according to an article in today's
Wall Street Journal
quoting here China's Commerce Ministry
said Thursday that a sale or divestiture
of tick tock will involve exporting
technology that has to be approved by
the Chinese government
continuing to quote the reported efforts
by the Biden Administration would
severely undermine Global Investors
confidence in the U.S said shooting a
Ministry spokeswoman continuing to quote
if that is true China will firmly oppose
it she said referring to the forced sale
so despite your assertions to the
contrary
China certainly thinks it is in control
of tick tock and its software is that
not correct
Congressman uh Tick Tock is not
available in mainland China and today we
are headquartered in Los Angeles and
Singapore but I'm not saying that you
know the founders of bike dance are not
Chinese nor am I saying that we don't
make use of Chinese employees just like
many other companies around the world we
do you know use their expertise on some
engineering projects but according to
their Ministry spokes well then it would
be a defestiture of exporting technology
from China so they again China thinks
they own it even though you do not Madam
chair I just I asked consent to put
today's Wall Street Journal without
objection so order into the record
um Mr Chu I wouldn't ask you to discuss
any privileged attorney
client materials but uh did anyone aside
from your lawyers assist you in
preparation for today's hearing
I prepared for this hearing of my team
here in DC
did anyone at bite dance directly
provide input help or instruction for
your testimony today
Congressman this is a very high profile
hearing my phone is full of well wishes
it does you know but I prepared for this
hearing with my team here in DC
are you are you willing to share uh who
who helped prepare you for this hearing
with the committee and you can do I can
follow up with you okay like can you
guarantee that no one at bite dance had
a role in preparing you for today's
hearing
like I said Congressman this is a high
profile hearing a lot of people around
the world were sending me wishes and
unsolicited advice but I prepared for
this hearing my team here in DC
are the attorneys representing Tick Tock
also representing bite dance
yes I believe so
what percentage of tick tock revenue
does bite dance retain
just give me a ballpark estimate if you
don't precisely know
a congressman like I said as a private
company we are not prepared to disclose
our financials in public today
we ask you to get back to us with a
ballpark we're not asking for the
precise figures but they get so the
committee can have some understanding of
the percentage of tick-tock Revenue the
bite dance retains
I understand the question respectfully I
as a private company we are not
disclosing our financials today
prior to today's hearing did anyone
affiliated with the Chinese Communist
Party discuss this hearing with you or
anyone else on Tick Tock Senior
Management
a congressman since I've been CEO of
this company I have not had any
discussions with Chinese government
officials
so what
what but what about Chinese Communist
Party itself if any of those officials
discuss this with you like I said I have
not had any discussion with Chinese
government officials I don't know the
political affiliation of everybody I
speak to so I can't verify the statement
let me ask you a question in a different
direction a few weeks ago this committee
had a field hearing down in McAllen
Texas
and it was on the issue of Fentanyl and
illegal immigration
and one of our Witnesses uh Brandon Judd
a 25-year veteran border patrol agent
said that all social media platforms
play a role in illegal immigration
that's one of the ways cartels advertise
their services throughout the world and
convince people to put themselves in
their hands and come to the United
States the cartels all use social media
platforms are you aware of this
phenomenon
any content that that promotes human
abuse is a violative of our community
guidelines which dictates what is
allowed and not allowed on our platform
we proactively identify and remove them
from our platform it would be very
helpful if you would share with the
committee examples of how you have
removed people because what we heard at
the hearing was that Tick Tock was one
of the platforms that recruits
adolescents in the United States to help
with transporting people who are in the
country who've been trafficked into the
country as well as Contraband substances
would you help us with that
understanding who you have removed from
your platform Congressman I'll be
delighted to check my team and get back
to yours and be collaborative thank you
gentlemen's time is expired
shares recognizes the lady from
California Miss eshu for five minutes
thank you madam chairwoman uh Mr Chu
thank you for being here today
um
as members of Congress
are very first and top responsibility is
to protect and defend
protect and defend their Constitution
and the National Security of our country
so uh I view this
entire issue
uh now there are many parts of it that
are not part of our national security in
my view uh but first and foremost for
our national security
so uh in examining uh tick tock
breaking away from bite dance
I'd like to ask you some questions about
that and how
um
uh a
a
severance uh in terms of the
relationship with bite dance how
um user data American users data would
be protected
now under beijing's
um security laws
uh
article 7 compels companies to provide
data
uh article 10
makes the reach of the law uh extra
extra territorial now this is very clear
I don't need to read all of it uh into
the record uh but that's those are the
laws of uh of the PRC
how does uh bite dance
how does tick tock rather
how do you convince
uh the Congress of the United States
that there can be a clean break
uh why would the Chinese government
sidestep
their uh national law including article
7 article 10
um uh in terms of user data
Congressman thank you for the question
I'm glad you asked this as I said in the
opening statement our plan is to move
American data to be stored on American
soil by the American company I
understand that but uh uh but you're
sidestepping or I haven't read anything
uh in terms of tick tock how you can
actually say and you spoke in your
opening statement about a firewall
relative to the data
but the Chinese government has that data
how can you promise that uh that that
will move into uh into the United States
of America and be protected here
congresswoman I have seen no evidence
that the Chinese government has access
to that data they have never asked us we
have not provided well you know what
I've asked that because I find that
actually Preposterous I have looked in I
have seen no evidence of this happening
and in order to assure everybody here
and all our users our commitment is to
move the data in into the United States
to be stored on American soil by an
American company overseen by American
Personnel so the risk will be similar to
any government going to an American
company asking for data is that
well I'm one that doesn't believe that
there is really a private sector in
China
uh and when you look at their national
law and what specifically these two
articles article 7 and article 10 are
very clear so I I think that there is a
real problem a real problem relative to
our national security about uh uh the uh
protection of uh the user data I don't
believe that Tick Tock has uh that you
have sent or done anything to convince
us that uh that that information the
personal information of 150 million
Americans uh that the Chinese government
is not going to give that up so tell me
can you tell me uh who writes the
algorithms for tick tock today the
algorithm that powers the U.S user
experience is running in the Oracle
Cloud infrastructure yes you know in the
initially there were parts of the source
code especially in the infrastructure
layer that doesn't touch the user
experience now that's a collaborative
Global effort including built by
engineers in China just like many other
companies by the way the phone you use
the car you drive is a global
collaborative effort now but today the
business sites and the main parts of the
code for tick tock is written by Tick
Tock employees and
congresswoman what we are offering is
third party monitoring of our source
code I am not aware of any company
American companies or otherwise there
has actually done that because we are
saying we want to give you transparency
and rely on third parties to make sure
that we get all the comfort that we need
about the experience well I uh my time
is up and I yield back thank you
lady yields back
pleased to yield to the gentleman from
Ohio Mr Latta for five minutes
well thank you madam chair unlike the
Chinese Communist Party the United
States believes in individual freedom
Innovation and Entrepreneurship
that is in part why Congress enacted
section 230 of the communications
decency Act
our goal is to promote growth of the
online ecosystem in the United States
and to protect companies from being held
liable for good faith efforts to
moderate their platforms
last year a federal judge in
Pennsylvania found that section 230
protected Tick Tock from being held
responsible for the death of a 10 year
old girl
who participated in a Blackout Challenge
also known as the choking challenge
Tick Tock actively pushes video on her
feed
unfortunately this is one of the many
devastating examples of children losing
their lives because of content promoted
by tick tock
section 230 was never intended to Shield
companies like yours from amplifying
dangerous and life-threatening content
to children
do you consider this to be a good faith
moderation
hmm
Congressman as a father myself when I
hear about the tragic deaths my question
people you find that good faith
moderation
well Congressman section 230 is a very
complex you know yes or no
I we are very focused on safety and all
these stages
do you believe Tick-Tock deserves this
liability protection
I'm sorry Congressman you believe that
Tick-Tock deserves this Library
liability protection under Section 230.
Congressman as you pointed out uh 230
has been very important for freedom of
expression on the Internet it's one of
the commitments we have given to this
committee and our users and I do think
it's important to preserve that but
companies should be raising the bar on
savings I really agree let me follow up
real quickly from your own testimony
when you told us and you repeated it
we'll keep safety particularly for
teenagers a top priority for us when
you're saying you're making that
following commitment why do you have to
wait till now to make that following
commitment now and not having done it
before when this ten-year-old lost her
life
Congressman I'm reiterating the
commitment internally in all my in all
my priorities which is public domain
okay
this company is a picture-perfect
example of why this Committee in
Congress needs to take action
immediately amend section 230.
when we recently met I asked you if the
Chinese Communist Party can currently
access user data and you do not have a
clear answer so today I want to follow
up you heard it a little bit but I want
to be absolutely sure of this answer
are employees of bite dance subject to
Chinese law including the 2017 National
Intelligence law which requires any
organization or citizen to support
assist and to cooperate with State
intelligent work in accordance with the
law
like many companies including many
American companies we rely on the global
Workforce including engineers in China
okay but no yes no so in the past yes
I'm in the past yes yes but we are
building project taxes and we're
committing the firewall of all protected
data foreign
of the 2017 National Intelligence law
which I just said because it says in
addition as it was asked a little bit
earlier the 2014 counterintestinal
Espionage law states that when the State
security organ investigates and
understands the situation of Espionage
and collect relevant evidence the
relevant organizations and individuals
it does not say may it's a shell
provided truthfully and may not refuse
yes or no
do any bite dance employees in China
including Engineers currently have
access to user us user data
today all U.S user data is stored by
default in the Oracle Cloud
infrastructure and access to that
there's control any American Advanced
employees in China including Engineers
currently have access to U.S data
uh Congressman I would appreciate this
this is a complex uh topic today all
data yeah it's not that complex yes or
no do they have access to user data we
have after project Texas is they aren't
done the answer is no today there's
still some things we've heard originally
the ranking members here he hasn't and
if he doesn't really see that uh project
Texas is going to be useful
so I think I'm taking that as a no
because again
the question is what came to come up
earlier on that on December the 22nd of
last year when bite dance confirmed some
of its Chinese employees had access
Tick-Tock data to Monitor and track
Monitor and track the physical location
of journals
so I took that as a yes from an earlier
answer you know earlier this week you
posted a tick tock videos asking
American users to mobilize in support of
your app and oppose the potential US
Government action to ban Tick Tock in
the United States based on the
established relationship between your
company the Chinese Communist party it's
impossible for me to conclude that the
video was anything different than the
type of propaganda the CCP requires
Chinese companies to push on its
citizens now yield back
gentlemen yields back
chair recognizes the lady from Colorado
Ms to get for five minutes thank you
Matt thank you very much Madam chair Mr
Chu like my colleagues I'm concerned
about the influence of China on Tick
Tock and what that does for U.S users
but I'm also concerned about how the
content in Tick Tock is being
distributed particularly to young people
this is not a problem unique to Tick
Tock but Tick Tock has 150 million users
in the United States and so I think
you'll agree that Tick Tock has a
particular responsibility to monitor
content to make sure that it's safe and
accurate would that be fair to say yes I
agree with that so
um you know I know you said in your
opening statement there's a ban on for
or limited for kids under 13 and under
18 and so on but I'm I'm I I know it
won't be news for you that that computer
savvy kid kids actually can bypass some
of those restrictions quite frequently
and they can do it even if they have
parental oversight and so what I want to
ask you is is rather than putting the
burden on young people and parents to
accurately put in the birth date and so
on when registering for tick tock I want
to ask you what Tick Tock can do to make
sure to monitor this this content and I
want to give you some examples of some
of the extreme content Mr Latta talked
about the Blackout Challenge and the
date some of the dangers to Young
people's safety but there's also extreme
content around Health Care information
in one study 13 out of 20 results for
the question does mugwort induce
abortion it's it talked about herbal
so-called abortivations like papaya
seeds which which don't work and so if
people searching for information on safe
abortions went on Tick Tock they could
get
devastatingly incorrect information
another
another study showed that Tick Tock was
had a hydro hydroxychloroquine tutorial
on how to fabricate this from grapefruit
now there's two problems with that
number one
hydroxychloroquine is not effective in
treating covid so that's one issue the
second issue is you can't even make
hydroxychloroquine from grapefruit so
again this is a really serious
miscommunication about health care
information that people looking at at um
at Tick Tock are able to get and in fact
it's being pushed out to them so I want
to know from you and I will give you
time to answer this you have current
current controls but the current
controls are not working to keep this
information mainly from young people but
from Americans in general what more is
is Tick Tock doing to try to strengthen
its review to keep this information from
coming across to people
thank you for the question
um congresswoman the dangerous
misinformation that you mentioned is not
allowed on our platform it violates them
I'm sorry to report it is on your
platform though uh congresswoman I I
don't think I can sit here and say that
we are perfect in doing this we do work
very hard how can you make yourself more
perfect I don't want you to say it's not
there or you apologize what can you do
to limit it as much as possible more
than what you're doing now we invest a
significant amount in our content
moderation work I shared their number in
our in my resume I know you're investing
but what steps are you taking to improve
the AI or whatever else you're doing to
limit this content for example if you
search for certain Search terms we do
direct you on Tick Tock to Resource
safety resources that's one of the
things we have done we will continue to
invest in this I recognize and fully
align with you that this is a problem
that faces our industry that we need to
really invest and address this I'm very
in alignment the vast majority of our
users come to our platform for
entertaining safe content but there are
people who do have some who do spout
some dangerous misinformation and we
need to take that very seriously invest
in it proactively identify it and remove
it from our platform okay I'm going to
stop you right now I asked you
specifically how you were increasing how
you're trying to increase your review of
this and you gave me only generalized
statements that you're investing that
you're concerned that you're doing work
that's not enough for me that's not
enough for the parents of America I'm
going to ask you to supplement your
testimony and have your have your
experts tell me what you're doing to
make this a higher level of scrutiny not
just pablum at a hearing thank you I
yield back thank you lady yields back
chair recognizes gentleman from North
Carolina Mr Hudson for five minutes
thank you chairwoman Morris Rogers for
holding this important hearing I
appreciate the witness Mr Shoji Chu for
making yourself available here today
while many consider Tick Tock to be just
another video sharing app in reality
Tick Tock has been functioning as a
massive surveillance program collecting
vast loss of personal data for more than
a billion people worldwide this includes
data from the personal devices of
federal employees contractors and most
concerning U.S military service members
and their families at places like Fort
Bragg in North Carolina
as Fort Bragg's Congressman I have
serious concerns about the opportunities
Tick Tock gives the Chinese Communist
party to access the non-public sensitive
data of our men and women in uniform
this personal data and location
information can be harvested and could
be used for blackmail to conduct
Espionage and possibly even reveal true
movements while the Department of
Defense and most agencies have banned
tick tock on government issue devices I
believe more needs to be done at the
command level to urge troops and their
dependents to erase the app from the
personal devices and keep them off home
Wi-Fi having an app banned on a device
in one pocket but download it on your
device and the other doesn't make a lot
of sense to me I believe Congress and
DOD should address the continued use of
tick tock on military installations as
well as any use that depicts U.S
military operations Mr does tick tock
access the home Wi-Fi network
only if the user turns on the Wi-Fi I'm
sorry I may not understand that so if I
have a stick talk app on my phone and my
phone is on my home Wi-Fi network does
tick tock access that Network
it will have to to access the network to
get connections to the internet if
that's the question is it possible then
that it could access other devices on
that home Wi-Fi network
Congressman that we do not do anything
that is beyond any industry Norms
um I believe the answer to your question
is no it could be technical let me get
back to you okay I'd appreciate if you
can answer that I'd like to change
directions real quick
um do you receive personal employment
salary compensation or benefits from
bite dance yes I do what is your salary
from bite dance
a congressman if you don't mind I would
prefer to keep my compensation private
good you personally have any company
shares or stock in bite dance or doyen
if you don't mind I would like to keep
my personal assets private
is Tick Tock the company your only
source of employment compensation
where's your other source of income
outside of tick tock
it's my only source of compensation
do you have any Financial debts or
obligations to bite dance Dorian or any
other bite dance Affiliated entity
personality no I do not
does your management team receive
separate salary compensation or benefits
from bite dance
we receive salaries from the employee
the entities that we are employed in but
we do share in uh the employee stock
option plan that is available from from
the bike dance
uh top company so you're so your primary
salary comes from Tick Tock but you have
other compensation that comes directly
from by dance you can characterize it as
that yes
does your management team have company
shares or stock in bite dance or doing
um yes uh we some of our employees are
compensated in shares in by dance
does tick tock share technological
Resources with doyin
are the two technology systems or I.T
systems interconnected in any way there
are there's been many companies some
shared resources on some services but it
doesn't include anything that involves
U.S user data congressman is in Project
Texas as we talked about stored by
default in American soil but currently
there is shared technology
or interconnected
RT systems Congressman with respect I
have to get back to you this could be a
very broad question like for example we
could all be using Microsoft Windows
if you could get back with details on
that I'd appreciate yes
um Can doian Personnel or employees
access Tick-Tock user data
not after project Texas this is not
allowed
are there employees who are employed by
both doyen and tick tock
I do not believe so
okay and so
I don't believe so is that it I mean if
again I'll allow you to come back and
read response if you could give me a
definitive answer I will go back and
check to be very sure okay thank you
um
I'm also concerned about an issue that
our chairwoman brought up
um about an apparent pattern of
misinformation misrepresentation from
your company in regards to the amount
and extent of data that you're
collecting as well as how much been
success from inside China there are
dozens of public reports that conclude
individuals in the People's Republic of
China have been accessing data on U.S
users directly contradicting several
public statements by Tick Tock employees
and I'm I'm referencing project Raven
which was first reported on by Forbes
last October
their investigation revealed I'm sorry
I'm about out of time do you want to
respond to that
yes Congressman
um we do not condone the effort by
certain former employees to access U.S
Tick Tock user data in an attempt to
identify the source of leaked
confidential information we condemn
these actions after learning about them
we found a highly reputable Law Firm
that thoroughly investigated the
incident we took Swift disciplinary
action against employees were found to
be involved and are implementing
measures to make sure this doesn't
happen again we have made this team
available to you that I think they have
briefed many of you in this committee
very extensively and I will continue to
make them very available to you as part
of our transparent commitment thank you
my times expired I yield back
yields back chair recognizes the lady
from Illinois
thank you
um so today
um in the Wall Street Journal
they said today uh China uh
um
uh China's Commerce Minister
said that China opposes the sale of tick
tock because it would involve export
exporting China's technology and would
uh and this is the important part and
would need to be approved by the Chinese
government
government so
um all of what you've been saying about
the distance between Tick Tock and China
has been said to be not true
um in the uh in the paper today and I I
would like to see what you have to say
in response
congresswoman I do disagree with that
characterization I think we have
designed project Texas to protect U.S
user interests and to move forward here
in the U.S again it's the protections of
storing American data on American soil
by an American company looked after by
American personnel and I do not think
that uh you know our commitments to this
committee and all our users is impacted
by by any event that you mentioned now
um the the whole you know discussion on
this um the resolution of this is an
ongoing and developing event so we will
continue to pay attention to this and
we'll get back to you when we have more
specifics so in my commitment stand yeah
okay so if it's an ongoing um debate
apparently with with China so it's hard
to say
um with any certainty that China would
not have any influence but let me ask
another question
um so um last fall along with gospel
Iraqis who were chair and coach chair of
the subcommittee together
we're told that Tick Tock had surveilled
uh was involved in in surveillance of uh
users very personal information
and you might say well not more than
other companies and I agree with uh
um ranking member pallone that I I
really don't want to go by that standard
particularly but that tick tocks in-app
browser surveilled everything from
Americans including passwords and credit
card numbers
Etc so I just want to ask you
um if if Tick Tock did track and collect
the sensitive data that Americans don't
want to have disclosed
Congressman thank you I'm glad you asked
this question because like you pointed
out we actually do not believe we
collect more data than any other social
media company out there a lot of these
reports and I we can talk about which
specific specific one you're talking
about a lot of them are not that
accurate some of them we have contacted
the we have actually gotten in touch
with the authors to help them understand
the data that we're collecting a lot of
it is speculation you know this is
something they could do they could do
but if you look at the subtext this is
something that so every company could do
I'm running out of time let me just say
that if tic-tock tells not to take this
incident this uh sensitive information
that you don't need for a transaction
and support our comprehensive privacy
bill that would be that would be very
helpful the other thing I wanted to ask
so um really this is this is a nest yes
or no
um that Tick Tock does tick tock share
user information from
um
companies from parent companies from
Affiliated or
um uh or send user information to uh
overseas
in the past yes for interoperable
interoperability purposes now after
project Texas all protected U.S data
will be stored here with the access
controlled by a special team of U.S U.S
Personnel again congresswoman this is
something that as far as I understand no
other company including American
companies are willing to go so maybe
this is a something that we can ask the
industry to provide not just us to
protect us in case of sharing
information I do want a quote from
employees that you had that and here's
the quote everything is seen in China is
really what they said people who were in
touch with the sensitive data
were saying that how do you respond to
that I I disagree with that statement
well I know you disagree with that
statement but my point is how does that
happen that employees of the uh of the
company are saying that in fact that's
not true
I cannot speak to I don't know who this
person is so I cannot speak to what the
person have has or has not said what I
can say is you know based on my position
in this company and the responsibility
that I have that statement is just not
true
okay unfortunately and I I'll close uh I
guess I'm over my time we need to look
into the facts of this and so do you and
I yield back
gentlelady yields back chair recognizes
the lady from Florida Ms kamek for five
minutes
thank you madam chairwoman Mr show are
you aware of Chinese Communist party
leader chairman XI jinping's comments in
May 2021 during a communist Bureau study
session where he instructed colleagues
to Target different countries different
audiences with short form video are you
aware of these comments yes or no
Congressman I'm not aware of these
comments okay well and as was pointed
out by chairwoman Rogers you have
regular contact with Chinese Communist
Party secretary Mr Zhang Fu ping who is
your boss at bite dance correct no no no
he's neither my boss nor do we have
frequent contact but you have regular
contact with bite dance
uh with uh the CEO of bite dance who is
Mr Zhang fuping is the editor-in-chief
he's not my colleague representative
Burgess uh a few minutes ago exposed
that Tick Tock and bike dance share
legal teams you confirmed this correct
our general counsel is yes an American
lawyer yeah also my colleague
representative Latta confirmed that your
parent company bite dance currently can
access user data yes let's uh we have to
be more specific yes after project Texas
no I'm not asking after project Texas
I'm asking now yes some user data is
public data congresswoman which means
everybody can see what's interesting to
me is that you've used the word
transparency over a half a dozen times
in your opening testimony and
subsequently again in your answers to my
colleagues yet the interesting thing to
me is that bite dance your parent
company has gone out of their way to
hide an airbrush corporate structure
ties to the CCP the company's founder
and their activities you can look no
further than the fact that by Dan's
website has been scrubbed in fact we
found web pages from the Beijing
internet Association the industry
Association charged with Communist Party
building uh work of internet companies
in Beijing they have been archived but
since deleted makes you kind of wonder
why yes or no bite dance is required to
have a member of the Chinese government
on its board with veto power is that
correct
no that is not correct the bike dance
owns some Chinese businesses and you're
talking about this very special
subsidiary that is for Chinese business
license so I'm gonna have to move on
you've said repeatedly that there is no
threat that this is an inner a platform
for entertainment and for fun I have to
ask you then if there is no threat to
Americans if there is no threat to our
data privacy security why did an
internal Memo from Tick Tock corporate
headquarters explicitly coach Senior
Management
to quote downplay the parent company
bite dance why would they say downplay
the China Association and downplay AI
this is from an internal Memo from your
company why if you had nothing to hide
would you need to downplay the
association with bite dance in China
congresswoman I have not seen this memo
UK question Mr show I'd like to direct
your attention to the screen for a short
video if you don't mind
[Music]
foreign
that video was posted 41 days ago as you
can see it has captioned me as f
at the house Energy and Commerce
Committee on March 23rd of this year
this video was posted before this
hearing was publicly noticed I think
that's a very interesting point to raise
but more concerning is the fact that it
names this chairwoman by name
your own Community guidelines state
that you
have a Firm Stance against enabling
violence on or off Tick Tock we do not
allow people to use our platform to
threaten or incite violence or to
promote violent extremist organizations
individuals or acts when there is a
threat to Public Safety or an account is
used to promote or glorify off-platform
violence we ban the account this video
has been up for 41 days it is a direct
threat to the chairwoman of this
committee the people in this room and
yet it Still Remains on the platform and
you expect us to believe that you are
capable of maintaining the data security
privacy and security of 150 million
Americans where you can't even protect
the people in this room
I think that is a blatant display of how
vulnerable people who use tick tock are
you couldn't take action after 41 days
when a clear threat
a very violent threat to the chairwoman
of this committee and the members of
this committee was posted on your
platform
you damn well know that you cannot
protect the data and security of this
committee or the 150 million users of
your app because it is an extension of
the CCP and with that I yield back can I
respond chair
no we're going to move on
General lady yields back
chairman recognizes the lady from
California Miss Matsui for five minutes
thank you very much Madam chair and I'm
really glad that we're having this very
important hearing here today
and let me just say make no mistake the
Chinese government represents a real and
immediate threat
look no further than even the vulnerable
gear still in our Telecom networks that
needs to be we have to generally place
but we can't lose sight of the important
internet governance issues Tick Tock and
other social media companies represent
I'm especially committed to demanding
transparency from large platforms about
the algorithms that shape our online
interactions especially for teenagers
and young users
and that's why I introduce the
algorithmic justice and online platform
transparency act to bring greater
visibility into this ecosystem
my bill would require would prohibit
algorithms that discriminate on the
basis of race age gender ability and
other protected characters
characteristics it also would establish
a safety and Effectiveness standard for
algorithms while requiring new forms of
intersight oversight
now this bill would require online
platforms to publish annual public
reports detailing their content
moderation practices
which I believe should be a baseline
requirement to enable meaningful
oversight
and consumer choice
Mr Chu just yes or no do you believe a
requirement for annual contact
moderation practices for social media
platforms would be beneficial yes or no
yes
this transparency bill would also
require online platforms to maintain
detailed records describing their
algorithmic process for review by the
Federal Trade Commission in compliance
with key privacy and data identification
standards Mr Chu does tick tock
currently maintain records describing
their algorithmic processes yes or no
Congressman I would need to check and
get back to you on what kind of specific
records you are talking about I wait for
that
over the past few years alarming
information brought to light by
whistleblowers have shown that social
media companies are intimately aware of
the effect their products have on young
women political extremism and more
despite this they withheld those studies
or declined to investigate further
in either case it shows a pattern
evasive or negligent behavior that I
find concerning in the extreme
Mr Chu does tick tock conduct its own
studies on the effect of his algorithms
and content distribution models on
mental health or safety and if so how
and when are those findings made public
and if not do you believe they are
necessary
congresswoman we rely on external third
parties and fund their research to help
us understand some of these issues for
example we worked with the digital
Wellness Lab at the Boston Children's
Hospital to understand the 60-minute
time limit that we put for all our under
18 users and we are supportive of
legislation that provides more funding
for research like for example for the
NIH okay
um Tick Tock tailors is recommended
content based on user activity to
encourage people to spend more time on
the app while this practice is by no
means unique to tick tock given the
prevalence of young users and the
digestible nature of short form video
I'm concerned about the app's tendency
to exacerbate existing mental health
challenges Mr Chu does tick tock have
different policies for amplifying
contact that would be related to
depression or dieting versus content
like gardening and sports
if yes describe these policy differences
if no why not
congresswoman thank you for that this is
a great question the answer is yes we
are trying out some
um policies together with experts to
understand certain contents they are not
inherently harmful like Extreme Fitness
for example but shouldn't be seen too
much and uh this is these are models
that we're building and we are trying to
understand you know together with
experts how to best Implement them
across our platform particularly for
younger users in cases where users have
been engaging with potentially harmful
content
I believe it's imperative that the app
takes steps to moderate that behavior
rather than continuing to promote it
that means in a sense I apologize I I
know about that I wasn't clear first
anything that is violative and harmful
will remove what I meant to say were
things content content that is not
inherently inherently harmful like some
of the Extreme Fitness videos about
people
running 100 miles and it's not
inherently harmful but if you show them
too much the experts are telling us that
we should disperse them more and make
sure that they're not seen too regularly
so especially about that then it's
something that you we are working on it
yes yeah you're working on it yes okay I
yield back
Jenny gentle lady yields back chair
recognizes gentleman from Florida Mr
Bill Ruckus for five years five minutes
thank you madam chair I appreciate it
very much thanks for holding this
hearing Mr Chu your algorithms have
prioritized providing harmful contact
directly to children like self-harm
challenges and even suicide just three
days ago Italy opened an investigation
into the tick tock over user safety
concerns after the so-called French scar
challenge went viral on your platform
I know you know about the Blackout
Challenge which Others May know as the
choking challenge that encourages
children to bring them to the point of
unconsciousness or in some cases
tragically death
if that uh if that isn't enough
I want to share the story of Chase Nazca
a 16 year old boy from New York who
tragically ended his life a year ago by
stepping in front of a train
I want to thank his parents again they
are here I want to thank his parents for
being here today and allowing us to show
this Mr chews your company destroyed
their lives
your company destroyed their lives
I admire their courage to be here and
share Chase's story in the hopes that it
will prevent this from happening to
other families
the content and chases for you Paige was
not a window to Discovery as you boldly
claimed in your testimony it wasn't
content from a creator
that you invite to roam the hill today
or stem education content that children
in China see
instead
his for you page was sadly a window to
discover suicide
it is unacceptable sir that even after
knowing all these dangers you still
claim Tick Tock is something Grand to
behold
I want you to see what Chase would see
and I think if you want again would you
share this content with your children
with your two children would you want
them to see this
and again I I want to warn everyone
watching that you may find this content
disturbing but we need to watch this
please
you got to kill yourself a word
like right now and then I'm gonna put a
shotgun in my mouth and blow the brains
of the back of my head
cool
this is a cute story My Brother who is
addicted to painkillers blew his head
off on the State Street Bridge bam
now hold on it gets better no letter no
goodbye nothing got a question
would you miss me
Mr Chu
Mr Chu please your technology is
literally leading to death
Mr Chu yes or no do you have full
responsibility
for
your algorithms used by Tick Tock to
prioritize content to its users yes or
no please
uh Congressman I'll just like to if
respectfully we don't mind I would just
like to start by saying it's devastating
to hear about the news of yes as a
father myself this is yes or no I'll
repeat the question
do you have full responsibility over the
algorithms used by Tick Tock to
prioritize content to its users yes or
no please Congressman we we do take
these issues very seriously yes or no
and we do provide resources for anyone
who types in anything that sir yes or no
I see you're not willing to answer the
question
or take any responsibility for your
parents companies the technology and the
harms it creates
it's just very very sad very sad it's
very sad this is why Congress needs to
enact a comprehensive privacy and data
security law to give Americans more
control over their information and to
protect our children we must save our
children from Big tech companies like
yours who continue to abuse and
manipulate them for your own gain
and now I'll yield back
Madam chair gentleman yields back chair
recognizes the the lady from Florida Ms
Castor for five minutes well thank you
madam chair colleagues it is urgent that
the Congress pass and and online data
Privacy Law that protects the personal
privacy of Americans online and
particularly our kids while this hearing
shines a light on tick tock
uh this hearing also should serve as a
call to action for the Congress to act
now to protect Americans from
surveillance tracking personal data
Gathering and addictive algorithmic
operations that that serve up harmful
content and has a corrosive effect on
our kids mental and physical well-being
for many years I've sounded the alarm in
this Committee of how big Tech platforms
like Tick Tock and Facebook and
Instagram
incessantly surveil track gather
personal private information and use it
along with data Brokers to Target and
influence our Behavior this is a much
broader issue than Tick Tock in China
there are other malign actors across the
world who gather data to use it as an
element of social control uh and
influence peddling uh and worse and as I
detailed in this committee last year
when we passed the on our online Privacy
Law the harms to children are very
serious and demand Swift action big Tech
platforms profit immensely from keeping
children addicted they do not care about
the Privacy safety and health of our
kids uh they are the modern day tobacco
and cigarette companies that for so long
resisted and misled Congress and it took
the Congress
it took action by the Congress to to
actually protect our kids and to Outlaw
smoking by by young people
in early 2020 based upon the growing
body of evidence evidence to harm uh to
kids online I introduced the kids
Privacy Act and the kids act and I want
to thank all of the researchers the
young people
the parents the Surgeon General of the
United States who have explained the
correlation between social media usage
and body dissatisfaction disordered
eating habits anxiety depression
self-injury suicide ideation and cyber
bullying heck Francis Haugen the
Facebook whistleblower was right here
and testified to us that Facebook and
Instagram conducted research on this
topic they knew and understood the harms
but they continued to elevate profits
over the well-being of children
and Tick Tock does the same
last Congress when we passed the adppa
the committee Incorporated many of these
important child online privacy and
safety Provisions from my bills but we
can make the 118th congress's version of
this bill of this new law even more
protective of children and I look
forward to working with the children
Hawk has incredible sway over children
in the U.S
but you don't have a very good track
record uh in in 2019 Tick Tock was hit
with the largest civil penalty uh by the
Federal Trade Commission in the
children's privacy case four years later
Tick Tock still has not taken sufficient
action to fix the problems I assume
because child users are incredibly
profitable to your bottom line
um
so answer me this Tick Tock allows
advertisers to specifically Target
advertising to children age six thirteen
to Seventeen correct
congresswoman um I do want to disagree
with the statement that child abuses are
not allowed enough is deplorable conduct
and it's not allowed on our platform
Target advertising to to young people
age 13 to 70. we do self-personalized
advertising at this point and the
policies are very safe how much money
does
ads targeted to minors
uh Congressman can I clarify minus in
what age from just say age 13 to 70. for
the teenager population I want to
clarify that we do have a 13 under 13
experience and that zero advertising on
that on that platform for those well
that's a whole other
top
between 13 and 17 if you don't mind I'll
check into my team and get back to you
on those answers you know Tick Tock
could be designed to minimize the harm
uh to kids but a decision was made
uh to aggressively addict kids in the
name of prophets and it's our
responsibility members to act swiftly to
address this this has gone on for too
long we've Dilly died too much this
committee thankfully we've taken
responsibility and acted but we have an
enormous responsibility to act swiftly
and get this bill to the floor of the
house and passed into law as soon as
possible thank you I yield back my time
General lady yields back chair
recognizes the gentleman from Ohio Mr
Johnson for five minutes thank you madam
chair
um Mr Chu I'm I'm an information
technology professional been doing it
for the most of my life you've been
evasive in many of your answers I want
to talk to you in some language that
maybe you'll better understand ones and
zeros okay
let's talk about the citizen lab report
this is something your team frequently
mentions in hearings as a way to
exonerate yourself for example in the
limitations section it reads we could
not examine every source code component
and test in the apps in every
circumstance which means our methods
could not find every security issue
privacy violation and censorship event
so it's an incomplete assessment the
report notes that tick tock's data
collection using third-party trackers
was an apparent conflict with the gdpr
and that multiple themes were censored
by tick tock what is shocking to me is
the shared source code between Tick Tock
in the United States and the CCP
centered Dolan the citizen Labs report
says that many of the functions and
classes were identical and that the
differences in Behavior between Tick
Tock in the United States and doing in
China are slight changes in hard-coded
values incredibly specific censorship
parameters from doing are present in
Tick Tock but just turned off
the authors say that for unknown reasons
the parameter variable itself is
preserved so while citizen lab may have
been afraid to say the obvious
conclusion Mr Chu I am not Tick Tock
source code is riddled
with back doors and CCP censorship
devices
here's the truth in a million lines of
code the smallest shift from a zero to a
one
on just one of thousands of versions of
tick tock on the market will unlock
explicit CCP censorship and access to
American data
Mr Q as CEO of tick tock why have you
not directed your engineers to change
this source code
Congressman thank you for the question
have you directed them to change the
source code like what we are offering in
my fourth commitment have you directed
them to change that source code
Congressman if you give me a bit of time
to just no I I don't it's a yes or no
question have you directed your
engineers to change that source code I
I'm not sure I understand why are you
allowing Tick Tock to continue to have
the capacity for censorship and yet you
claim here that you don't let me remind
you of something do you realize that
making faults and misleading statements
to Congress as a federal crime yes okay
so have you directed your engineers to
change that source code I am giving
third party access monitoring by experts
and uh
source code is the same as Dolan what
percentage I can get back to you on the
specifics okay I'd appreciate that where
was the source code for tick tock
developed was it developed in China or
in the United States it's a global
collaborative effort like a lot of the
development was it developed in China
some of it some of it is okay it might
dance can can the when it's compiled in
the compilation process can byte code be
manipulated we've talked a lot about
source code what about the byte code the
ones and zeros that actually execute on
the device
Congressman to give you a company that's
why we're giving third party monitors
yes as an expert I think you can agree
that very few companies I've got the
report here by uh citizen lab I want to
read you uh something from Ron diebert
specifically in your written testimony
to Congress you stated on page nine
citizen lab found that there was no
overt data transmission by Tick Tock to
the Chinese government and that Tick
Tock did not contact any servers within
China you implied that citizen lab
exonerated Tick Tock from any
information sharing with China well the
director of Citizen lab saw this and
issued a statement correcting the record
yesterday and I'm quoting Ron diebert
the director of the lab I am
disappointed that Tick-Tock Executives
continue citing the citizen Labs
research in their statements to
government as somehow Expo exculpatory
I've called them out on this in the past
and it's unfortunate that I have to do
it again unquote he goes on to say and I
quote we even speculated about possible
mechanisms to which the Chinese
government might use unconventional
techniques to obtain Tick-Tock user data
via pressure on bite dance end of quote
Mr Chu you sent Congress first written
testimony citing this lab as a support
of your claim that China cannot access
user data U.S user data and now this lab
has come out to say we never said that
that's misleading Mr Chu I hope you
understand what that is that's
misleading Mr Chu this is yet another
instance of tick tock attempting to
mislead Americans about what their
technology is capable of and who has
access to their information Madam chair
I'd like to uh
and the uh citizens lab into the record
without objections with that I yield
back gentleman yields back chair chair
yields to the gentleman from Maryland
Mr sarbanes five minutes uh thanks very
much Madam chair Mr true I'm going to
pick up on a theme we've already covered
here which is the effect that your
platform along with many other social
media platforms by the way has in terms
of
uh mental and Behavioral Health in this
country I won't speak to what's
happening elsewhere in the world but
we've talked about the impact that it's
having on children on teens
we took some action last year in this
committee to try to improve access to
resources reauthorize critical programs
to address mental health needs but we
need to do even more than that and we
got to address with the big tech
companies like Tick Tock are doing
because those are platforms that expose
children teens to
to additional risks the more time that
middle and high schoolers spend on
social media the evidence is the more
likely they are to experience depression
and anxiety and this is particularly
troubling since apparently 16 percent of
American teenagers report that they use
tick tock
quote almost constantly that's I think
about 5 million teenagers in this
country that are on Tick Tock
um all the time
and we know that big Tech including Tick
Tock uses design features that can
manipulate users including children's
and teens to keep them engaged designed
to feed them a never-ending stream of
content keep their attention for hours
on end which includes capitalizing on
the desire for others approval through
like features preying on the fear of
missing out through push notifications
and so forth
um again you're part of an industry
that's set up to do this you in some
sense don't appear be able to help
yourselves in reaching out and finding
that new user and then holding on to
them
Tick Tock itself is acknowledged that
these features and others like the
endless scroll feature can have an
outsized effect on teens
um and we've been discussing today how
your app only intensifies that harm
by amplifying dangerous content and
misinformation
I don't want to be too paternalistic
here because we have young people in the
audience we've got Tick-Tock users that
are watching this hearing and I'm sure
they have their own ideas about how this
technology is being managed by Tick Tock
and other social media platforms
um they like to access the platforms and
they should be able to do that safely so
it's certainly in their interest and
they can drive this conversation I think
perfectly well but it's not a fair fight
is it I mean the algorithms are on one
side of the screen the human brain is on
the other side of the screen drowning in
these algorithms in many instances at an
age where where the brain's not even
fully developed yet so those addictive
impulses are being sort of perfected by
the technology and again it leaves the
users sort of helpless in the face of
that are you looking at ways to redesign
core features like the ones I mentioned
to be less manipulative
manipulative excuse me and addictive for
users and can you commit to making some
of those modifications here today
Congressman um thank you we do want to
be leading in terms of safety of our
users particularly for teenagers we were
the first to launch a 60-minute watch
limit yeah let's talk about the
60-minute lunch and I'm very glad to see
people others in our industry follow for
many of your recommendations we'll study
them very seriously we actually have a
series of features like for example if
you're under 16 you cannot use a direct
messaging feature because you know we
want to protect those younger users if
you're under 16 you cannot go viral by
default if you're under 18 you cannot go
live and let me go back to the 60 Minute
limit
um because my understanding is that
teens can pretty easily
bypass the notification
to continue using the app if they want
to
I mean let's face it our teams are
smarter than we are by half and they
know how to use the technology and then
get around these limits if they want to
are you measuring how many teams
continue to exceed the 60 Minutes of
time on that app we understand that's
how that's working we understand those
concerns what we Our intention is to
have the teens and their parents have
these conversations about what is the
appropriate amount of time for social
media that's why we give the parents
what we call family I ask you this
question before I run out of time if you
concluded that putting some reasonable
limits in place and trying to find a way
to enforce them would lead some
percentage of your users to leave Tick
Tock and go somewhere else is that
something that you're prepared to accept
yes really well I'd love to get the
research on how these limits are being
implemented how they're being bypassed
and the things that you're taking uh the
measures you're taking to address those
issues going forward please bring that
information back to our committee as we
move forward
I yield back gentlemen yields chair
recognizes gentleman from Kentucky Mr
Guthrie for five minutes thank you madam
chair for for yielding I appreciate the
time uh Mr Chu your terms of service
specifically state that Tick Tock does
and I quote not allow the depiction
promotion or trade of drugs or other
controlled substances
despite this content being against your
terms of service and I brought this up
with other service providers but despite
this content being against your terms of
service content on your platform related
to illicit drugs like fentanyl drug
trafficking and other listed activity is
pervasive and racks up hundreds of
thousands of views for example in 2020
the Benadryl challenge resulted in the
death of an American Teenager when we
heard of another one challenge earlier
today that brought a death of a teenager
or you were a bite dance if you were the
CFO for bite dance did doing
allow related illicit drug trafficking
or challenges resulting in death or
injury to kids
a congressman I represent Tick Tock here
today I can tell you that Tick Tock does
not allow illegal drugs just do in it do
it did in China I believe they don't
allow this but I will need to check I
don't run their business
does not allow this is what we're
concerned about and my guess and and it
would would do and allow for 41 days a
threat against a member of the Chinese
Communist party to stand on their web on
their site for 41 days
again I cannot speak for toen and I'm
sorry I didn't hear the second part of
what you said well we had a threat
against the chairman of our committee
that was on your side for 41 days my
guess is that would not be allowed in
China that content is is violated I
would look into the specifics and I
would it would if it violates our
guidelines you'll be taken down on Tick
Tock yeah surely it appears that it does
but the problem is that I'm what I'm
trying to get at is you seem to be able
to prevent
this content in China
but you so not even taking it down just
prevent it from being posted and yet it
it's it's all it's on your website so I
have a couple of questions about uh you
you said earlier as soon as you find
this information you take it down so how
quickly does your algorithm detect
keywords or content that involve illicit
drug trafficking before these posts are
self-reported or used by others we have
about 40 000 people working on this now
together with the machines that we train
I don't think any company in our
industry can be perfect at this this is
a real big challenge for industry but
our goal is to get this any violative
content including illegal drugs down to
a very very small number that's the
problem when we have these hearings we
have CEOs of different companies and and
of your your colleagues and competitors
and we always hear apologies and we
always hear we want to do better at this
but it it just doesn't seem to keep
improving and we see her hearing stories
of our of our children and and obviously
that's been talked about today so how
many posts and accounts have been
identified and removed from Tick Tock
due to content posts posted related of
drugs or other Controlled Substances
Congressman we do publish that in a
transparency report I can get my team to
get the information to yours thank you I
appreciate that also we understand that
that the way that people use tick tock
or other platforms similar to yours is
that uh they they ensure flag user
content isn't permitted to jump from so
my question so what we've heard is that
the instances the user see a drug
advertisement and then give a code to go
to another site so my question is do you
work with other platforms to ensure flag
user content is a permitted to jump from
one platform to others I would check
with my team I would love to work with
our industry to make sure that we stamp
out these problems you know violative
content should not be allowed on any
Platforms in my opinion well so what's
you know kind of frustrating to all of
us here is that we look at what's
happening on your sites and others and
particularly that that we know because
we've done a research that you can't
have access to the list of drug
information others on doing which is a
sister company as you say in China
and so it absolutely if you can prevent
it on one and not the other you
obviously have the ability to stop it
from moving forward and yet you don't
would you like to expand how one of your
sister companies can prevent that and
you're not I know you don't represent do
we end but they don't allow it but it
happens on your platform what's the
difference uh first of all the majority
of the content on Tick Tock is fun
entertaining uh informative and very
positive about users like other
companies that operate in this country
we have to deal with some Bad actors who
come and publish some content on illegal
illegal drugs you know other Bad actors
don't seem to be able to access doy in
uh The Tick Tock U.S experience should
be compared to other U.S companies
because this is common but your parent
company has the technology to prevent it
because you prevent it in China but you
can't prevent it here why what's the
difference that's why I'm asking oh
Congressman there is no technology that
is perfect in doing this we have to deal
with the reality of the country they
were operating in and here in the United
States as with other companies we share
this challenge we are investing a lot to
address the challenge but we are you
know it's a shared challenge you invest
a lot to seem to be able to address it
in China but not here uh again you know
I think the comparison has been within
the single country you know we Face the
same set of challenges here and there's
a difference I'm sorry I'm at a table
what's the difference in China and here
let me give you an example Congressman
in my home country Singapore there is
literally almost no illegal drug content
because Singapore has very strict drug
laws
thank you my time's expired and I yield
back
gentlemen yields back chair recognizes
the gentleman from New York Mr tonko for
five minutes thank you madam chair I'm
concerned that tick tock's algorithm
prize preys on vulnerable people
including those struggling with
Addiction eating orders disorders and
other mental health conditions a
platform is designed to push content to
users that will watch more frequently
and for longer periods of time
unfortunately for many people suffering
from certain mental health disorders
videos that reinforce their fears or
negative self-image are more engaging on
top of that Tick Tock has received
sensitive patient health information and
records of browsing activity from
multiple Telehealth companies like
better health help and cerebral
people's personal struggles should not
be fuel for tick tocks profits people
should be able to seek help to address
serious medical concerns without being
afraid that their information will be
shared with social media companies
trying to push more products services or
content at them so Mr Chu will Tic Tac
continue to get information from third
parties on its users Health including
their mental health yes or no
we will continue the work of experts yes
if that's the question we'll identify
this is well you'll continue to get
information from these third parties
including their mental health yes or no
Congressman sorry I may not understand
your question if your question is if I'm
working with them on these issues the
answer is yes
it's not the question it's will you
continue to get information from these
third parties on its users health
get information
um we do not get any user health
information from third parties
congressman
you've talked a lot about user privacy
and safety will you commit here today to
no longer using data about users Health
particularly their mental health to push
them content or sell ads yes or no we
take our users mental health very
seriously yes or no as far as I'm aware
we don't do that Congressman it's not
not what the uh so the answer is no you
will no longer use uh data about users
Health uh Tick Tock systematically
exploits users anxieties by pushing
alarming and distressing content onto
their for you page for example in May of
2022 the LA Times found that some
pregnant users searching for information
about their pregnancies on Tick Tock
were then shown information about
miscarriages still births and delivery
room traumas your company knows that
distressing content can have the
perverse effect of feeding user
engagement
and for tick tock engagement means money
in the course of a week what percentage
of content that a user sees is
considered potentially harmful or
distressing content Congressman we work
with a lot of experts on this even
before we set the 60 Minute time limit
for under 18s if you spend too much time
on our platform you can try it if you
spend too much time we will actually
send you videos to tell you to go out
and get some air and get off the plan
what percentage of content that a user
sees is considered potentially harmful
I would need to follow up with my team
and get back to you on that that's okay
ballpark I would need to follow up with
my team so our teenagers in particular
shown more distressing content
uh the opposite is true we actually put
in more restrictions to make sure that
our teenagers get a better experience
you know are expecting our new parents
shown more distressing content
I know of many parents uh including one
I met recently who actually use our
platform to find communities to connect
with other parents and learn a lot more
I've heard amazing stories of creators
who have difficulties you know and
reclaiming my time are individuals with
eating disorders show more distressing
content we do not re we remove all
content that glorifies eating disorders
and we have worked with experts to look
at certain inherently certain content
that may not inherently be harmful like
Diet Trends and and make sure that we
disperse them more throughout our
algorithm what about those with mental
health issues
if a user searches you know words that
expresses mental health issues we
actually redirect them to a safety page
like for example uh if you I don't know
if I should say this in public if you
search I want to die it will redirect
you to a safety page for example
so what about those suffering from
addiction are they given more
distressing content
I'm sorry Congressman I missed that
question
no suffering from addiction are they
given more distressing content
I missed the first few guys I apologize
those what about those suffering from
addiction are they given more
distressing content those suffering from
uh addiction addiction uh do you mean
drug addiction or yes or any any order
of addiction if if people search for
content and you can try on a variety of
subjects we will actually direct you to
a safety page to give you more resources
and a lot of recovering addicts have
actually found their communities on Tick
Tock and it's really helped them you
know find their voices and the community
and the courage to to Really overcome
their addiction I I personally have
heard stories of that
well I appreciate your answers but I was
looking for yes or no and we did not get
those and again I think the more that
they watch this distressing content the
more profit Tick Tock makes and that's
distressing
gentleman yields back chair recognizes
the gentleman from Michigan Mr Wahlberg
for five minutes thank you madam chair
and we're glad that you're here Mr Chu
as chair Rogers and representative
Burgess mentioned this morning the Wall
Street Journal reported that China will
firmly oppose any for sale or
divestiture of tick tock and this is
based not on conjecture but it's based
on comments provided by the official
spokesperson at the ministry of Commerce
who said that any Tick Tock sale or
spin-off would amount to a technology
export and would have to hear to Chinese
law and approval this spokesperson was
quoted as saying the Chinese and I quote
the Chinese government will make
decisions according to the law the
Chinese government
Mr Chu do you agree with this official
yes or no Congressman I cannot speak on
behalf of a Chinese government official
do you agree with that official we would
need to look at this because project
Texas is designed to move forward here
in the United States and we are not
discussing this so I don't have
specifics you know
your company is valued at upwards of 50
billion dollars
and has been on the verge of for sale or
ban for three years at least correct
do you expect this committee to believe
you haven't already discussed this
scenario with your team and you should
have an answer to this yes or no I agree
with a Communist party or I don't agree
with the Communist Party
so
I guess I would say at that point you
disagree
with a Commerce Communist Party explain
your discrepancy
Congressman for two years we spent a
billion and a half US dollars to build
project taxes this is after very
extensive discussions with project
relevances project tests is just
something expanded for the future
we're talking about now
we're talking about what you're doing
now what's your expectations are now
what your relationship is with the
Communist party which is our major
concern of what the impact that will be
with a country
let me rephrase that with a Communist
party that doesn't care about America
and sees us as standing in their way for
for superpower
that's our concern and for you to have
direct relationship uh direct ownership
with bite dance
and to not have a characterized
characterization or an agreement or
disagreement that you say explicitly
with this party policy
it's hard for us to to believe what
you're saying let me move on
following up on what Mr Latta asked
about data access by Chinese engineers
in responding to Mr Latta you talked
about where American user data would be
stored in the future
but the question was about access today
storage in the future versus access
today this is total redirection
this blows up any trust we could desire
to develop so to be clear Mr Chu today
do bite dance employees in Beijing have
access to American data
Congressman we have been very open about
this we have relied on global
interoperability you have access to
American data Congressman I'm answering
your question forgive me just a bit of
time we we rely on global
interoperability and we have employees
in China so yes the Chinese Engineers do
have access to global data they have
access to global data we have heard not
storage no storage has always been in
Virginia and Singapore
the the physical service you have no
access to storage
to American data today
that's not what I said I said so you do
have access
to American data and you have storage of
American data the American data has
always been stored in Virginia and
Singapore in the past and access of this
is on an as required basis as required
globally by Engineers for business
purposes private dance bite dance uh the
Communist party no no why how can you
say that this is if they have access
business this is a private business and
is like many other businesses many other
American companies we rely on the global
Workforce so the global Workforce that
includes bite dance
which is connected directly to the
Chinese Communist party that is the
characterization that we disagree with
now that's not what we can disagree with
that's a fact it's not unfortunate the
CEO of bite dance uh and your
relationship to them uh Congressman
respectfully in my opening statement I
said this is a private company it's
owned 60 by Global Investors three out
of the five board members on bite dance
are Americans this is a private business
new report directly to buy dance with
the CEO who is a member of the Communist
party let me move on he's not I think we
got the answer
uh sadly
um at this point
I believe my time has expired so I yield
back
gentleman yields back chair recognizes
Ms Clark for five minutes uh thank you
chairwoman Rogers thank the ranking
member cologne for holding today's
hearing uh throughout this hearing uh
I also want to thank our witness uh for
being here to testify on what are very
important issues before us today
throughout this hearing my colleagues
have outlined the potential threat posed
by the security of Americans data by
Tick Tock being Affiliated and some
would say owned by a Chinese company
foreign adversaries having direct access
to Americans data as well as the ability
to influence this content Americans see
on a prolific social media platform
represents an unprecedented threat to
American Security and to our democracy
however the problems of social media
platforms content moderation algorithmic
discrimination and safety are neither
new nor unique to tick-tock
Mr Shu I share the concerns raised by my
colleague congresswoman Matsui related
to algorithms I believe that without
mitigation against bias platforms will
continue to replicate exacerbate
discrimination that is illegal under
civil rights law as well as exclude
important dialogue about sensitive
topics like race from occurring on the
platform
for example I was disturbed by reports
that Tick-Tock content moderation
algorithm flagged words like black
or black lives matter as inappropriate
content
so my first question is to choose do you
agree that platforms like Tick Tock
should be subject to regular audits or
transparency requirements to identify
whether policies have a disparate impact
on communities that are protected
classes like race
religion national origin or gender
I think um uh congresswoman I think
platforms should be very transparent on
what they do there and disclose a lot of
information we can get back on the
specifics of what we mean by an audit
but I do agree very strongly that
platforms should be very transparent and
it's a commitment that we're giving to
this community and all our users that
our platform will be a place for freedom
of expression we embrace all diverse
points of view all ethnic minorities you
can come and say whatever you want as
long as you don't violate the rules of
safety that were put in place and we
will we also commit to be free of all
and any government manipulation so I
think I'm in strong agreement with a lot
of what you said well thank you my bill
the algorithmic accountability act would
require platforms to be transparent
about their algorithms measure disparate
impact
and require risk mitigation it is vital
that the diverse culture of the United
States is reflected online but I'm
concerned the algorithms and content
moderation practices employed by Tick
Tock are ignorant to the fundamental
diversity while also failing to remove
content that is harmful like child
sexual abuse material hate speech or
domestic terrorism content my next
question to you is it's my understanding
that users must be in good standing to
be eligible for compensation from tick
tock's Creator fund for example they
can't have violated Community guidelines
is this correct
uh there are some details there but
directionally yes if tick tock's
algorithm is flagging content
incorrectly resulting in creators
violating Community guidelines when in
fact they have not
those creators would not be eligible to
receive compensation under the Creator
fund correct we do have an appeals
process you have an appeals process okay
in my view if Tick Tock employs
algorithms that disproportionately
misremove content from black creators
it's disproportionately silences and
excludes black creators from
compensation opportunities and this
problem happens in parallel to the lack
of adequate recognition attribution and
compensation to Black creatives for
their content the exploitation cultural
misappropriations the Erasure of black
creatives ownership of their fashion art
and media is nothing new we need
transparency accountability and bold
action to mitigate against
misinformation bias and exclusion of
certain communities from the
opportunities present on platforms like
tick tock
so let me let me just say this
I'm concerned about transparency I am
concerned about algorithmic
accountability and I'm not clear that
your organization holds those values so
I want to ask that you uh take a look at
this uh because this is all part and
parcel of what we're concerned about
with respect to uh social media
platforms and the misappropriation uh
the uh
the ways in which those algorithms can
discriminate uh within the context of
the social media platform with that
Madam chair congressman is it okay if I
just very quickly respond this is a very
important topic unfortunately we only
have four and a half hours with you and
I'm gonna try to get to every member so
we're going to keep going this is very
important I would love it well there
will be other opportunities
the lady yields back gentleman from
Georgia Mr Buddy Carter is recognized
for five minutes thank you madam chair
Mr crew welcome to the most bipartisan
Committee in Congress we may not always
agree on how to get there but we care
about our our national security we care
about our economy and we sure as heck
care about our children
we sure do and that's why you're here
today because two-thirds of all the
youth in our country are on your on your
app
they spent an average of 95 minutes on
your app
and you know research has shown that
Tick Tock is the most addictive platform
out there
and and the reason for that is we've
been told is because it has the most
advanced algorithm
in the Chinese Communist Party knows
this and I don't speak for everyone but
there are those on this committee
including myself who believe that the
Chinese Communist party is engaged in
psychological warfare
through Tick Tock to deliberately
influence U.S children
you know you see behind me if you look
behind me Mr you see some of the
challenges that we've seen on Tick Tock
you know about them you know about the
milk crate you know about the uh about
the Blackout Challenge you know about
the uh NyQuil chicken challenge the
Benadryl challenge the dragon's breath
liquid nitrogen trend
are the challenge that promotes car
theft I want to ask you as I understand
it there's a sister app in China
doiken I'm sorry if I'm butchering the
the pronunciation
do they have these same things over
there
do they have these kind of challenges uh
China Congressman I'm really glad you
asked this question do they yes or no
I'm not sure because well come on now
you're not sure I really I'm not sure
remember you took
the the chair lady she said you got to
tell the truth okay
do you know whether they have these kind
of challenges like this over in China
because it's my understanding they don't
I I'm not sure because I spend my
energies running Tick Tock and and you
don't look at any of your other
competitors or look at anything similar
to yours so you don't know whether they
have they don't have this over in China
I did we have it here but they don't
have it here and that's that's why I'm
I'm asking you this why is it that Tick
Tock consistently fails to identify and
moderate these kinds of of harmful
videos
why is it why is it that you allowed
this to go on we've already heard God
bless you from parents who who are here
with us who have lost children
I I submit to you everybody
up here cares about the children of this
country
tell me tell me why
this is a real industry Challenge and
we're working no no the industry this is
Tick Tock is they're talking about Tick
Tock we're talking about
why is it that you can't control this
and although I believe in giving credit
where credits do I want to thank you
it's my understanding that the video
that threatened life of the chairwoman
has been has been removed thank you for
doing that sorry we had to bring it to
your attention here but it's been
removed tell me why this goes on this is
an industry challenge for all of us here
operating okay so much for industry
challenge I want to shift gears real
quick I want to talk about biometric um
Matrix and and I want to talk
specifically can you tell me right now
can you say with a hundred percent
certainty that Tick Tock does not use
the phone's camera to determine whether
the content that elicits a pupil
dilation should be Amplified by the
algorithm can you tell me that we do not
collect body face or voice data to
identify our users
no the only face data that you'll get
that we collect is when you use the
filters to have see sunglasses on your
face we need to know where your eyes are
why do you need to know what the eyes
are if you're not seeing if they're
dilated and that data is stored on your
local device and deleted after use if
you use it for facial again we do not
collect body face or voice data to
identify our users
I find that hard to believe it's our
understanding that they're looking at
the eyes how do you determine what age
they are then
we rely on age gating SL age dating
which is when you ask the user what HDR
we have also developed some tools where
we look at the public profile to go
through the videos that they post to see
whether that's creepy tell me more about
that it's public so if you post a video
that's you choose that video to go
public that's how you get people to see
your video we look at those to see if
you it matches up the age that you
talked about now this is a real
challenge for our industry because
privacy versus age Assurance is a really
big problem look look you keep talking
about the industry we're talking about
Tick Tock here we're talking about
children dying do you know any children
have died because of this do you have
any idea can you tell me uh Congressman
again it's heartbreaking can you tell me
how many children in America have died
because of challenges like this the
majority of people who use help platform
use it for positive experiences that's
not what I asked you they always ask you
tell me the number of children of U.S
children who have died because these
challenges Congressman again
the majority of majority of people who
come on our platform I'm not talking
about the majority of children I want to
know a number
dangerous changes are not allowed on our
platform if we find them we will remove
them we take this very obviously you
found one today and you removed it we
had to bring it to your attention and I
know I'm out of time thank you for being
here welcome again to the most
bipartisan Committee in Congress
gentleman yields back
we will now take a brief recess and
resume in 10 minutes the committee
stands in recess